here in the Maryland countryside the NSA
seems very far away but it's never far
from Thomas Drake's mind during the
toughest times of his battles with the
US intelligence agency this is where he
came to reflect now he's an outsider but
he's been closely watching the latest
round of a cooperation between the NSA
and Germany's bnd he says claims the
partnership went far beyond the original
agreement are wrong but this agreement
basically gave carte blanche and it was
really designed to provide NSA in
particular access to pretty much
anything they wanted to ask the B&D to
collect because the agreement allowed
interpretations that would give much
wider access to information beyond any
other restrictions even including German
law the German constitution or even EU
privacy laws the current Rao goes right
to the top of the German government
angler Merkel's office is accused of
duping voters by claiming that it was
about to reach an agreement with
Washington not to spy on each other's
countries Drake says that would never
have happened even the US is five eyes
alliance with the UK and other nations
doesn't go that far the truth be told
there's actually no written no spy
agreement even with the five eyes
community there isn't it's just this
understanding that we're not going to
routinely spy on each other a batch of
emails recently leaked to a newspaper
show Berlin couldn't even extract a
promise to obey German laws on German
soil but Drake says that was never going
to happen either they've never invited
by German paws in Germany I mean this
it's it's it's incredulous right well
Germany remains mired in these arguments
in the US the focus is now on possible
reform Congress is considering changes
to the NSA's mass gathering of american
telephone records that measures would
see phone
and he's storing the data instead of the
NSA itself but Drake says who stores the
data matters little while other concerns
aren't getting proper attention all the
other day that's collected we're talking
about email financial records internet
usage under other all that continues
unabated and the NSA's reach outside the
US remains untouched including in
Germany for Drake the most troubling
thing about the cooperation with the BND
is how it turns Germany's foreign
intelligence service against its own and
I should experience extraordinary alarm
bell for the citizenry when you're going
government by default and design by hook
or by crook is allowing its own foreign
intelligence service in particular to
operate in a rather unfettered manner on
its on itself oh I mean that's then it's
an alarm bell the Drake will be ringing
in Berlin in the coming weeks he'll be
joining other whistleblowers on a tour
of European capitals outsiders still
hoping to be heard